nick casario that's something that
happened today the texans gm spoke to
the media pre-draft press conference
we've seen some of those we'll see more
of those as we get closer to the draft
here is casario on the desean watson
situation and his current status with
the team
we're not going to really get into a lot
of hypotheticals a lot of speculation um
i'm not really good at that um maybe
somebody else is better than that than
than me i mean
if you want to speculate i go probably
go buy bitcoin and focus on that so
we're just going to focus on the things
that we can control which is kind of
getting ready for the draft and trying
to take advantage of the opportunities
to continue to add to our team and build
our roster um and we'll just take it one
day at a time and focus on the things
that we can control
i'd say we're ready for a full-blown
comedy night at houston texas
headquarters you can open with nick
casario then you bring out the big guns
in jack easterby
but the bitcoin gag if i'm gonna
speculate i go buy some bitcoin he
didn't even pause for people to not
laugh miles come on
yeah i know i mean like i get what he
was doing there he's trying to lighten
things up a little bit but when you're
talking about a guy who's facing 22
lawsuits for what he's facing those
lawsuits for i mean i feel like we could
have done without the joking there
because it's a serious matter and i know
what he was doing
but like
i i don't know read the room if we're
going to have a comedy night like that
to me is not the subject that we should
be joking about well he learned his
comedic timing and content from jack
eastwood so exactly i'm not surprised
i'm not surprised that he went there but
on on the more relevant point he didn't
get into anything and he's not going to
get anything about desean watson look i
i continue to believe
that unless deshawn watson finds a way
to get these cases resolved before the
start of training camp i think he's
showing up i think he's showing up in
anticipation being placed on the
commissioner's exempt list because if he
doesn't show up he stands to lose 20
million dollars this year between salary
fines forfeitures etc if he does show up
and gets put on the commissioner exempt
list which i think he will if there's
still
let's say more than five of these cases
pending
more than five i think he's probably on
the commissioner examples i hate to
reduce it to numbers like that but i
think there's a point where if he
whittles it down to like two or three
maybe they'll go forward and not put him
on paid leave but i think where we are
right now if he settles none of these
before training camp i think he's going
on the commissioner exemplist he's going
to get more than 10 million dollars from
the texans to not play for them in 2021
here's more from casario on whether he
expects to see watson
in the off-season program in houston
it's a voluntary program right so
players have the option to participate
in the program so it's a case-by-case
basis and each player will make the
choice they feel is best what we're
going to do is we're going to do what
we've done actually the past couple
months like the building's been open
we've had a multitude of players that
have been in here that come in the
building they test they go in the weight
room they work out they go through their
process so again whatever players are
here that choose to participate like
that's their choice and we're going to
create as good of a working environment
for the players as possible so when they
come here they feel comfortable and they
feel like they're improving as a houston
texan football player so that's what our
focus is going to be
man i thought i used my hands a lot when
i talk uh nevertheless
desean watson is not going to be there
for the voluntary offseason program he
won't be there he wasn't going to be
there and there's no reason for him to
show or not show
now
because i don't think if he shows up
they'd put him on the commissioner
exempt list now
maybe they would i remember when tyreek
hill got himself into an issue a couple
of years ago there was just kind of an
agreement that he wouldn't be there for
the offseason program and then they took
it up again at training camp and he was
able to attend i just don't think it's
going to be an issue i don't think
desean watson is going to show up for
the offseason program unless he thinks
that that would force the league to put
him on paid leave now but i don't think
that it would
interesting because i i would sort of
think that
if he does show up i mean i guess right
now it kind of doesn't matter and if he
does show up that's not for really at
least another month because nobody would
really see him on the field until otas
start and that's in late may so maybe
it's going to be a moot point by then
who knows but i think it would be at
least
i don't know
it would be a very interesting thing if
he actually were there and you know
cameras would be able to either
photograph him or take video of him on
the field with his teammates doing
drills while all of this is still going
on and we also know that he requested a
trade and didn't ever want to play for
the texans again i think that if he does
show up which who knows if he will or
won't that would create a very
fascinating situation
yeah i i i would guess that he's not and
and the need to put him on paid leave
would be minimal because i doubt
there'll be much media access to these
offseason workouts because of the
pandemic the pandemic protocols still
are in place which means significantly
restricted media access and even if
there's normal media access it's not
like they have fully open practices for
reporters there's a minimal period
that's open and then it's
politely they're told please leave uh
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports